given the recent events that have taken
place in the united states and i'm
thinking about the storming of congress
by white supremacists i presume you feel
like this month couldn't come
soon enough in the u.s well
that is certainly the case the fact of
the matter is we're grateful that there
is
a period of time that is designated
called african-american history month
uh which gives as you stated the
opportunity for
people to learn and know the history of
african americans and the contributions
that have been made to our nation for
example
uh you know many people don't know the
traffic light was created by an
african-american
the city of washington dc was laid out
by benjamin banneker and
african-american
and the list goes on and on so it gives
an opportunity to recognize
but in light of and in the backdrop of
what happened
on january 6 most importantly it was
significant
that 81 million americans came together
to elect a new president
that is taking us in a totally different
direction
which i believe is positive and i want
to ask you about that i mean do you
think president biden will be able to
heal the divides that are ever more
present in the united
states i believe if given an opportunity
and over time the short
the short answer is yes but it's not
going to be a short period of time
it's going to take time for this to
happen i think that you know
getting the pandemic under control which
is the most important issue that he and
his team are working on
right now uh then uh figuring out how to
get the economy back working so that
people
can take care of themselves and their
families by having
viable options in terms of jobs those
are two first steps
that need to take place very soon uh
interesting who he chose as his vice
president how did you feel when you saw
karma harris
taking the oath that was a monumental
moment
in the history of our nation uh on
several fronts the first
front of course is the fact that she a
woman
has now been elected you know we had 44
45
vice presidents no women 44 45
46 presidents no women so we now have
the prospect of a woman first who's been
elected for the first vice president
who happens to be an african-american
and uh
and an asian so it is actually
phenomenal it
for little black girls like my daughter
it's like black this is magic
it was a magical moment and amanda
gorman as well stood out on inauguration
day so much didn't she
oh my god she there's so much talent in
uh
in the nation really in the in the world
but in our nation and in the
african-american community
uh that young lady is beyond amazing
uh we think about one of the last great
poets of our time
the late maya angelou dr angelou was
incredible
this young woman perhaps can fulfill
some of the
the shoes of maya angelou and just
quickly because we're running out of
time just tell us how much you
hope you have for the black lives
movement in the coming days and weeks
so i i think the black lives movement
number one
because it is constantly engaged and
because it is engaged with whites
and many around our nation that we're
going to see
great strides in a very short period of
time i think the president and the vice
president
are certainly dedicated and are
determined to make a difference so i'm
very pleased
where we are right now but there's a lot
of work to be done